>> Laura: IT'S TIME FOR OUR
"SEEN AND UNSEEN" SEGMENT WHERE
WE EXPOSE WHAT'S BEHIND THE BIG
CULTURAL STORIES OF THE DAY.
WE KICK OFF TODAY'S EDITION WAS
SOMETHING SO RIDICULOUS THAT IT
HAS TO BE SEEN TO BELIEVED.
THIS IS A CANDIDATE FOR CONGRESS
MAKING A COMPLETE BUFFOON OF
HIMSELF IN A DESPERATE BID FOR
VOTES.
HERETO FOR FILL US IN IS THE
AUTHOR OF THE BEST-SELLING
AUTHOR SERIES WILL WHILE -- KEEP
>> HE FEELS CONGRESS HAS BEEN
TALKING OVER EACH OTHER IN
REGARD TO SCHOOL SAFETY.
THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION WOULD
LIKE TO ARM TEACHERS.
TILLMAN HAS A DIFFERENT APPROACH
AND HE DEMONSTRATES IT.
>> AND POWER SCHOOLS AND
TEACHERS WITH NONLETHAL SELF
DEFENSE TOOLS, LIKE THIS CAN OF
PEPPER SPRAY.
TRUST ME, THIS.
ANYONE.
IN THEIR TRACKS.
NOW I JUST CAN'T SEE ANYTHING.
FOR LESS THAN $1 PER PERSON IN
THE U.S., WE CAN HAVE A SECURE
CANISTER OF PEPPER SPRAY IN
EVERY CLASSROOM IN AMERICA.
IT'S UNBEARABLE, IT'S LIKE A
LULLABY YOUR EYES.
>> THE AD IS LIKE A LULLABY IN
EYES.
>> THANK GOD HE IS NOT A WILD
GAME ADVOCATE.
HE WOULD BE SETTING OFF BEAR
TRAPS AND BLEEDING ALL OVER THE
FLOOR.
>> Laura: HE LOOKS LIKE HE IS
WATERBOARDING HIMSELF.
IN THE END I WANTED TO SPRAY
MYSELF WITH PEPPER SPRAY SO I
DIDN'T HAVE TO WATCH.
>> HE COULD HAVE A NEW SHOW
CALLED THE CANDIDATES AGAINST
THE WORLD.
HE COULD BREATHE IN CARBON
MONOXIDE, DRINK TOILET WATER --
>> Laura: AND THERE IS A
CERTAIN TYPE OF BLACK SPIDER
THAT'S ON THE ENDANGERED SPECIES
SO I'M LIVING WITH HIM.
AND, HE'S A DEMOCRATIC CANDIDATE
FOR A HOUSE SEAT IN COLORADO.
>> Laura: DISTURBING.
SO WHAT'S GOING ON WITH THE
BISHOP OF TUCSON?
AT ONE POINT, THE BISHOP OF
TUCSON, ARIZONA, AS YOU
MENTIONED, EDWARD WEISS AND
BERGER SEEM TO MORALLY EQUATE
THOSE ENFORCING THE BORDER WITH
PEOPLE COMMITTING ABORTIONS.
SPEAKING ABOUT BORDER SECURITY
THAT TAKES THE PART IN
SEPARATING FAMILIES.
WATCH.
>> IN LIGHT OF THE PENALTIES
THAT ARE THERE FOR LIFE ISSUES,
I'M SIMPLY ASKING THE QUESTION
IF PERHAPS OUR AFFAIRS COMMITTEE
COULD GIVE RECOMMENDATIONS TO
THOSE OF US WHO ARE BORDER
BISHOPS ON THE POSSIBILITY OF
CANONICAL PENALTIES FOR
CATHOLICS WHO ARE INVOLVED IN
THIS.
FOR THE SALVATION OF THESE
PEOPLE'S SOULS.
MAYBE IT IS TIME FOR US TO LOOK
AT CANONICAL PENALTIES.
>> MAYBE IT'S TIME FOR YOU TO
READ A CANON LAW.
WHAT IS HE TALKING ABOUT?
>> CANONICAL PENALTIES MEAN
RESCINDING THE SACRAMENTS.
I GOT A CALL FROM SOME BORDER
SECURITY GUYS.
I SAID WHEN NANCY PELOSI GETS
THE LETTER OF RESIGNATION YOU
CAN WORRY.
BUT THE PACK CATHOLIC          W
BUT THE PACK CATHOLIC          E
BUT THE PACK CATHOLIC          H
BUT THE PACK CATHOLIC          V
BUT THE PACK CATHOLIC          E
BUT THE PACK CATHOLIC          T
BUT THE PACK CATHOLIC          O
BUT THE PACK CATHOLIC          C
BUT THE PACK CATHOLIC          M
BUT THE PACK CATHOLIC          E
BUT THE PACK CATHOLIC          U
BUT THE PACK CATHOLIC          P
WITH POLICIES THAT DON'T
INCENTIVIZE PEOPLE TO SEND THEIR
CHILDREN ALONE ACROSS THE BORDER
CHILDREN ALONE ACROSS THE BORDE
BORDER.
THAT'S WHAT'S HAPPENING NOW.
AND THAT'S HAPPENING IN YOUR
HOME COUNTRY AND HERE.
>> AND ORDERLY.
ALL RIGHT, WHAT DOES GOD LOOK
LIKE?
60 SECONDS.
>> THE UNIVERSITY OF
NORTH CAROLINA DID A STUDY, FIVE
YEARS AND 11 AMERICANS.
THIS IS WHAT THEY THINK GOD
LOOKS LIKE.
>> >> Laura: THAT LOOKS LIKE OE
OF THE GUYS IN THE CONTROL ROOM
IN NEW YORK.
>> IT'S NICK ROBERTSON, HE IS
BASICALLY A NICE WHITE GUY.
NO.
PEOPLE TEND TO PROJECT THEIR
IMAGE AND THEIR BELIEFS ONTO
THEIR IMAGE OF GOD.
SO I THOUGHT, I WOULD WE DEFINE
GOD?
SO I CAME UP WITH MY OWN IMAGES.
HERE IS WHAT I THINK.
FRANK SINATRA AND JOHN HOUSTON
IN THE GREATEST STORY.
NOW YOUR PICKS.
>> Laura: MY PICKS ARE
CHARLTON HESTON -- THAT SEEMS
LIKE GOD.
GOD CAN'T LOOK LIKE THE KID IN
THE APPLE COMMERCIAL, LIKE
MACINTOSH VERSUS PC.
THAT'S LIKE A MILLENNIAL THING.
LIKE GOD HAS SKINNY JEANS, A MAN
BUN AND HE IS ALSO A BOY.
>> WE WANT A GUY WITH SOME
AUTHORITY AND GRAVITAS BUT I
THINK WE CAN AGREE THAT GOD DOES
NOT LOOK LIKE THIS.
>> Laura: THESE TWO.
I NEVER BOUGHT EITHER ONE OF
THOSE.
>> YOU WANT GOD TO SOUND LIKE
HIM.
>> GEORGE BURNS WAS HILARIOUS.
>> WE DON'T WANT GOD TO SOUND